okay here we go I'm gonna say it is a  biscuit oh snap son that's right I'm  going to say it is a sweet I'm good at  something being tight  they know that toilet nailing it  alright afternoon I'm going to say how  amazing true that true to the matter  what the hoop pull the other one asking  for another beer vodka beer is it  alcohol toilets and alcohol two things I  nail  hey let's go drinking yeah yeah a slam  acting like I got all these right Gladio  is that Daddy that right amazed okay a  cool picture I like the one about the  lizard and the tongue I'm busy or I'm  flat-out lying drinking lizard water  it's like it's like a muscle I'm gonna  say that from now and that's what you  think  that's all I'm gonna say no I love this  he's great I'm using all these terms I  feel from knockout round now now good  right was that you guys hear that is  that right um a group I googled it